[Applause]
all throughout the years
king has been one of the most used
characters in tekken
from tekken 1 to tekken 7 king has
always been present
and was always a very entertaining
character in tekken tag 2
there was once a player who was
considered as arguably the best king
player of the game
and his name is triple h
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is colin brown and welcome to
another ochoto tv episode
a forgotten legend
though triple h wasn't that active in
tech and crash days
he suddenly became popular when tekken
tag 2 came out
with his high rank in the arcades using
king and armor king
people would often watch videos of his
death matches against other tekken gods
[Music]
even though he wasn't included in some
big international tournaments
he was still considered as one of the
best players in tekken tag two
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
when tekken 7 had its early release
triple h was looking really good playing
king
he would deliver a great performance in
the twitch tech and crash tournament
representing team indigo's along with
rang chu
and loja
oh
vacuum
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one more hit one more one more
[Music]
eight seconds and one chance oh wow
three zero
[Music]
[Music]
after the tournament triple h then
became inactive
there was also no record of him ever
playing tekken 7 fr
some say that he already got a job and
just decided to quit playing the game
it would be interesting to see triple h
coming back
just imagine him having a mirror match
with nbc or
little maja that's it for this episode
of forgotten legends
for more tech and content don't forget
to subscribe to ochito tv
i can't see any tears in your eyes
tell me how i know by your voice
i'll be saved